[Musique]
et
bonjour à tous merci nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de vip aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler d'un événement
exceptionnel à savoir la présence d'un
rhinocéros à versailles on est
évidemment au xviiie siècle et pour nous
parler de cette incroyable histoire nous
avons l'auteur du roman alexandra de
broca le roman s'appelle un rhinocéros à
versailles alexandra de broca bonjour
bonjour bon je vous allez bien oh oui ça
va merci nous avoir rejoint son plateau
tv soixante dix huit pour ce vip qui
vous est entièrement consacré alors on
va faire un petit peu connaissance avec
vous avant de parler de ce roman vous
avez travaillé longtemps comme
scénariste à la télévision pour france 2
alors j'étais ce conseil est là
commencent les conseillers à l'erreur et
puis après quand j'ai quitté france 2 gt
scénariste il n'y a pas de scénariste
attitré dans une chaîne de télévision
oui je dis un peu de sorties au musée
pas grave l'essentiel c'est d'avoir
travaillé dans la fiction d'accord sur
des baux programme est un programme que
les versaillais je crois beaucoup
beaucoup aimé qui s'appelait l'allée du
roi déjà et voilà mes bébés hockey et
vous êtes aussi historienne de formation
formation chaire jean tulard qui m'a
permis d'avoir cette passion pour le 18e
et la révolution c'est votre époque ses
manettes peuvent définitivement oui j'ai
dû aller aux mails au moyen-âge voilà
donc vous êtes auteur justement c'est ce
qui vous amène sur ce plateau vous avez
écrit quatre romans et soutien j'écris
quatre romans qui tournait autour de la
famille de louis saez et de
marie-antoinette que ce soit safiullah
soit là vous avez écrit un livre sur la
leur fille oui la sonnaz s efface
effecté vous avez écrit un livre sur la
princesse de lamballe c'était la grande
amie de marie antoinette parce que j'ai
été très frappé par cette notion
d'amitié si fort qui fait qu' elle est
revenue des migrations il faut soit
sinon gérer ça et demi et bien sûr
madame elisabeth qui est un personnage
passionnant la salade la soeur de louis
saez absolument passionnant et puis
voilà et puis pour wc danse était pas et
c'est celle-là nous avons bon un
rhinocéros bien évidemment c'est un
événement qui est de démarrage de ce
roman mais nous avons une héroïne
imaginaire nous avons pour la première
fois la wind imaginaire légère
s'étalèrent la soigneuse
j'avoue que c'est assez agréable dacia
oui on a un peu le trac quand on écrit
sur quelqu'un qui a existé et kiki et
pas n'importe qui jamais tandis que
façonner le caractère d'un d'une héroïne
bas c'est assez amusant je peux dire ça
vous a plu c'est peut-être plus facile
en tout cas oui plus de liberté de tous
les instants alors on est toujours dans
cette période qui vous est cher à savoir
post révolutionnaire pré révolutionnaire
c'est à dire des choses c'est marrant je
vous donne toujours postés près ça veut
juste dire le contraire bon c'est comme
les gentils amont aval pour l'eff la
gauche de la rade voilà moi raconter
mais c'est une période de tout à fait
intéressante et c'est surtout une
période à versailles passionnante parce
que lorsqu en octobre 89 la famille
royale a quitté versailles pour paris ça
a été une catastrophe économique et
enfin même psychologique pour les
habitants de versailles voilà alors
justement tout ça on l'aperçoit au
travers de votre roman donc un
rhinocéros aversenq alors il est centré
dans la ménagerie qui est autour à côté
du château dans les dents park dans le
parc où existait aujourd'hui mais qui
est dans le parc voilà et j'avais juste
envie de dire trois lignes du prologue à
la rené en 1784 et le duc de noailles
qui est un peu le la personne qui le
super intendant super à dire dangereux à
la clinique du château etc alors il
écrit sa majesté le roi louis saez
doigts pour tenir son rang posséder
ménagerie composé d'animaux rares ne pas
avoir de zèbre ou d'éléphants est
indigne du domaine dont il a la charge
voilà alors justement qu'est ce qui
s'est passé avec cette espèce de grosse
bestiole
bien en fait comment est elle arrivée là
en fait depuis depuis très très très
très longtemps
les souverains étrangers
d'afrique ou d'asie envoyés en cadeau
diplomatique des animaux alors on le
sait pas mais le pape au xvième siècle
il a reçu un rhinocéros par exemple si
aussi et évidemment il fallait que ça
soit plutôt des lions des tigres qui
venaient d'asie remariage de reese
animaux enfin on n'en voyait pas juste
une perdrix ou
même un zèbre c'est moins bien une
limite c'est un peu limite limite il y
avait une forme de concurrence entre les
ménageries ah ouais bien sûr alors y
avait en france avec la ménagerie de
chantilly tenus par les condés en
autriche avec la famille habsbourg qui
avait elle aussi une ménagerie est donc
louis xiv lui il a commandé il a acheté
ces animaux il les a fait venir mais
après et louis 15 et louis cei se sont
totalement désintéressé de ce principe
d'avoir des animaux dans cette
magnifique ménagerie peut-être parce
qu'il était chasseur et que je ne suis
pas un chasseur moi même mais peut-être
qu'un chasseur un animal derrière une
cache c'est pas ça le voilà et après
peut-être aussi qu'il ne mettait pas
leur leur autorité leur puissant ego
demandant dans la seconde à lyon ah ben
jelloun est pas besoin de sa valeur à la
veille de la révolution il y a encore
beaucoup d'animaux qui sont dont la des
cadeaux diplomatiques comme le
rhinocéros
est bon c'est pas quoi en faire c'est à
dire que par quand arrive la fin la fin
c'est cette période où le château est
endormi et ben il va bien falloir
trouver des solutions pour ces
malheureuses animaux et puis aussi pour
les les gens qui travaillent à la
ménagerie voilà et c'est ça le sujet du
livre voilà c'est ce qui se passe à 7 à
ce moment là avec la révolution voilà
donc déjà avant que le château
s'éteignent ils s'endorment comme vous
dites on sait déjà pas très bien
s'occuper des animaux n'ont de toute
façon il ya passé commun c'est comme un
huit clos comme un lieu fermé à
l'intérieur du domaine de versailles et
franchement personne ne vient alors ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que ces animaux
cette ménagerie appartient
au roi c'est mon chose de privé d'accord
vous avez à paris au jardin des plantes
qui s'appelle jardin roy et à l'académie
des sciences des gens passionnants qui
sont buffon daubenton par la suite et
d'autres qui eux sont passionnés par le
monde animal qui veulent étudier et donc
en fait ce qu'ils veulent c'est
évidemment pouvoir étudier sans aucune
difficulté les animaux du roi d'accord
alors le roi il laisse évidemment tous
ces gens venir à la ménagerie mais ça
reste un versailles le seule chose qui
se passait quand un animal meurt alors
il est envoyé au jardin du roa paris
pour être disséqués puis naturalisé et
toute la bagarre va être d'essayer de
faire changer le statut ils savent hier
c'est à dire d'obtenir que ces animaux
en fait appartiennent à la france
d'accord c'est le début des eaux pour
que et ça va être donc effectivement le
début des eaux pour que les français
profitent et apprennent en voyant les
animaux parce qu'on pense qu'en voyant
les animaux
en les étudiant on peut mieux comprendre
le comportement humain et celui qui
était le plus féroces adversaires de
cette ménagerie privé basse et diderot
qui a des liquidités roger zidrou et 10h
oiseuses fameuse il dit puis il est
inadmissible de nourrir des animaux
quand le peuple de france meurt de faim
mais voilà et voilà on y est tous dit
oui voilà et alors donc cette fameuse
clair donc est est ce que donc elle et
soigneuse est elle elle part avec son
rhinocéros pour aller au jardin des
plantes bon il va ce qui sépare ce qui
séparait les responsables ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'en pleine terreur en
pleine révolution ces fameux
scientifiques ont dit que il fallait
faire quelque chose avec ces animaux au
contraire de chantilly ou là les animaux
ont été massacrés tout simplement un
petit bas beaucoup de canon le pauvre
tigre à la baïonnette les habitants de
chantilly les ont massacrés donc à
linverse ces fameux scientifiques ont
convaincu la convention de les
transférer voilà c'est complètement fou
donc imaginer le le trajet donc de
versailles
jusqu'à la seine jusqu'à meudon
rhinocéros ces deux tonnes et ensuite
par bateau jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient
maintenant donc le jardin des plantes le
quai d'austerlitz et donc on les a
réinstallé là et on a ouvert le premier
au public d'accord et en tenant cette
fois ci quand même content au maximum de
leur bien-être un petit peu nos gens
plus que ce à quoi je paye les cadres
elle a dit je crois que les cages
étaient pas plus grand de gens pas que
voilà oui pardon il faut pas oublier que
l'ennemi principal pour ces animaux
venus d'afrique c'est le froid oui bien
sûr ouais ouais mais bon moi j'ai quand
même l'impression que cette fameuse
clair la soigneuse qui va devenir un peu
la vétérinaire et la période vettel est
d'accord avec un vétérinaire elle elle
va à l'encontre de tout ça pour elle les
animaux ont des sentiments
ont besoin d'affection de soins elle est
très précurseuse elle est devenue la
curieuse mais le maisons alfort et c'est
à dire la première école vétérinaire et
crée aussi à ce moment là d'accord tout
c'est l'appel 12 ça c'est le début alors
s'est pas créée pour s'occuper des
animaux de compagnie s'est créé pour
essayer d'empêcher les épidémies
avec les chevaux
quand vous êtes en train de faire la
guerre et que vous avez la cavalerie qui
va charger si vous avez une épidémie et
que tous les chevaux sont dans les
écuries vous perdez la guerre et donc
maisons alfort a été créé pour réfléchir
sur l'aim des épidémies pour protéger
son protégé dit guy ouellette et du
cheval incroyable d'accord et alors ce
que j'ai beaucoup apprécié aussi dans
votre monde où l'histoire est
complètement rocambolesque et qui est
plausible enfin tassées complètement il
ya des faits complètement réel c'est
qu'on vend à des personnages satellites
autour de cette fameuse jeune fille
claire qui cas un sacré tempérament et
louis saez l'appelle mademoiselle
l'effrontée et puis elle va jouer un
rôle aussi dans la un rôle assez court
mais elle va quand même beaucoup
s'occuper du dauphin pour vos pauvres
enfants meurent j'avais envie de
l'évoquer l'histoire du dauphin on ne
parle que du petit louis 17 qui mordent
une issue tragique mais effectivement on
oublie qu'il y avait un autre ancien et
qui est mort au début tout est codé tout
au début de la révolution et qui est
mort dans des conditions terribles de
tuberculose osseuse qui est souvent
souffrances atroces et qui visiblement
était un petit garçon avec un esprit
plus que plus que mature est étonnant et
qui a laissé parmi les contemporains à
tous les gens qui ont écrit sur lui tous
étaient fous d'admiration pour ce petit
garçon et j'avais envie sur ce livre là
aussi d'évoquer à nouveau louis saez et
marie-antoinette mais de les évoquer
comme des parents je n'avais pas envie
de repartir dans la politique de savoir
si elle avait été bien ou mal j'avais
juste envie de montrer que à roi et une
reine à un moment donné où le sentiment
maternel
ce secret profondément évidemment dans
les familles aisées bien entendu comment
il vivait cette cette maladie et cette
agonie noël xti qu'ils étaient ils
étaient des parents très affectée
puisque marie antoinette est la première
à imposer que ces enfants vivent à
versailles à l'angle avant les enfants
des rois n'était pas élevé à versailles
éloignés voilà et donc c'est clair
heureuse va distraire ce fameux dauphin
et il ya d'autres personnages il ya son
fiancé qui est un gars de suisse oui
donc là encore enfin chaque personnage
représente un peu toutes les facettes de
cette de ce moment très précis charnière
juste au moment où la révolution arrive
et donc il ya le gain de suisse on a le
frère qui révolutionnèrent mais c'est
moi l'argent ce sont des gens entre
guillemets du peuple et je pense que le
personnage de claire qui n'a pas d'idées
politiques
il ya dû y avoir beaucoup de gens comme
ça
tout le monde n'avait pas cette
conscience politique tout le monde
n'était pas
à savoir ce qui allait se passer après
là-bas la chute de la bastille où
messieurs je pense que pour beaucoup de
ces gens là ça ne les intéressait pas
forcément ce qui les intéressait c'était
d'avoir un travail et de pouvoir nourrir
leurs enfants par exemple j'ai vraiment
c'était la base alors le garde suisse
par contre ça c'est tout de même des
gens extraordinaires mais oui n'ont pas
souvent dont on est enfant on était
alors des martyrs des vins oui un marin
cette atroce enfin je veux dire bon et
et donc voilà c'est ça qui enrichit kiki
que je trouve très très riche dans votre
roman c'est cette histoire de rhinocéros
bien évidemment la condition des animaux
et voilà et cette femme cette jeune
femme qui qui entouré de personnes qui
représente vraiment de vivre les 210 au
quotidien oui dans le rappel dans leur
bulle au départ un peu peut-être très
grand et après ben qui s'ouvre voilà ben
écoute et alexandra d'avocats un grand
merci monsieur vraiment pour ce roman
qui est passionnant et là je trouve qui
peut être lu par des ados dès qu'ils
aiment l'histoire qu'ils l'écoutent
c'est un style les pluies il est plus
fluide que les eaux à la plus facile et
les poteaux et les connaissent que voilà
donc ça peut plaire même allée des
jeunes 15 ans 16 ans jetons vert mais
c'est sûr c'est pour un public très
large mais voilà à très bientôt j'espère
on vend à tous merci de nous avoir
suivis
[Musique]